good morning believe nation today's
message is cultivate your strengths over
to you Steve I the thing that you're
most comfortable with that you do the
best because that's what you're gonna do
castle you know from like me
I've got strengths and I've got
weaknesses I don't work on my weaknesses
I ignore them and I cultivate my
strengths the level of achievement that
we have at anything is a reflection of
how well we were able to focus on it
because the only thing that's holding
you back is the way you're thinking I
love this message because I think too
many people try to focus on their
weaknesses and trying to round
themselves out instead of focusing on
what they're really good at and you be
the best in the world I remember if you
want to have tremendous success you have
to do something that you can be one of
the best people in the world at and the
only way to do that is with you go
all-in on your strengths instead of
trying to round out your weaknesses I
get a lot of people run into be saying I
want to start a tech company and I'm
wondering if I need to learn programming
to do the start the tech company if you
are not already into tech and already a
programmer and already diving deep into
that stuff and have ambitions to be one
of the best programmers in the world
then there's no point trying to learn it
right understand what you're really
great at if you're the visionary guy if
you're the business guy then don't try
to learn code instead focus on being
what you can be amazing at and then
partner up with people who can round out
those weaknesses and help you build the
ideal company if you look at most
entrepreneurs schedule you're probably
spending only 20% of your time actually
doing the things that you are but
tension one of the best people in the
world at and 80% of your time doing
stuff that really you shouldn't be doing
instead you want to flip that and be
spending 80% of your time doing the work
that you are amazing at and only 20% or
less on the stuff that you're not so
that's how you build a great company so
my question today today guys for you is
what are you the best in the world act
and are gonna start spending more of
your time
doing leave it in the comments below and
I'm gonna join a discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso